welcome and thank you for joining our
breakout session on playing fair I'm
David I'm a product manager with Google
Play commerce I'm responsible for user
trust on the last year Jonathan I have
been working together closely with a lot
of developers thinking about how we
would create a more fair and balanced
platform for your apps and your games
thanks David
hi everyone my name is John McGuire and
I'm a partner Development Manager here
at Google Play and David and I are
really excited to come talk to you about
the ways that we can make developing for
Android better so we titled this talk
playing fair and part of this means
maintaining a fair in-game economy in
your games so you can build sustainable
long-term businesses on our platform so
that's the general topic of what we're
going to cover today so now go into the
agenda so briefly I'm going to talk
about what playing fair means for Google
Play and then I'm going to hand it over
to David and he's going to talk about a
really cool product announcement we have
today but we're actually going to spend
most of the time talking with you the
developers so we have two developers
here we're going to invite on stage and
we're going to engage in a fireside chat
format with the discussion on what
playing fair means to them the
principles their priorities their
challenges and then if we have some time
at the end we'll save it for you guys to
ask us some QA but nothing too hard so
when we started down the path of playing
fair
we started with two main goals the first
was that we wanted to balance in-app
purchase economy so if you think about
when you have a game and you have a
currency in your game users pay money
for that currency and so you're
assigning a monetary value to that
carnist currency and we want to be want
you to be able to preserve this so you
control that and you have the full
control over that so that was the first
objective that we have the second thing
is that we want to do the right thing
for all users and this means that for
good users we want to provide a fair and
you know rewarding experience on our
platform but we also importantly want to
deter the bad users and so when we
combine those two objectives we hope
that we can achieve wins
you the developers the users and us is
google play so let me talk about our
principles to achieve us achieve these
goals the first is that we want to do
the right thing for all users all the
time and this sounds like a really big
googly lofty goal but really it starts
with assuming that all users and all
developers are inherently good and we
really believe that and so when they're
inherently good we can provide them
access to all of our services and that's
a really important trait to us but we
know from experience in probably you do
too that not all users are good and
there's a very small minority of them
that aren't good and so we have to
evaluate everything on a case-by-case
basis or an interaction by interaction
basis and sort of to highlight this let
me let me bring up an example so who
here in the audience is made and in-app
purchase before it's a good showing I
know I have myself and so let's assume
that you know you give a developer some
money and in turn you get in-game
currency let's call them coins now let's
suppose you want a refund for those for
your purchase well in today's in-app
purchase world you get your money back
but you also keep your coins which is a
little bit weird when you think about
that in the physical world that would be
like going to buy a vacuum and wanting
to return the vacuum and get a refund
but actually keeping the vacuum and
that's a little bit weird and so when
you think about a good user who wants a
refund they should be willing we believe
that they should be willing to give up
their in-game currency and to get their
money back
now we think about the bad user and they
might not want to give up their currency
but it's still the right thing to do and
so in all cases both the good the good
user and the bad user giving up the
currency is the right thing to do and we
believe that so we took these two
principles and we combined them together
and we built an API and the API will
allow you the developer to access all of
your refunds for your games so that you
can take back the currency from the
users whether they're good or they're
bad and make your game more balanced
and that's kind of the big product
announcement we have today so I'm going
to hand it over to David it's for him to
talk more about this so thanks John
so it's to Ferdie we're in the basement
and we're going to talk API school um
yes so what I'm going to do I'm gonna
talk a little bit about like how generic
this API works then I'm going to give
you some examples we've been piloted for
about ten twelve months now and then
also give you some examples about how
some developers we work with have
actually implemented this and made huge
huge gains so I'll do a lot of
simplifications if you have any
questions go find Jonna me afterwards
and talk to us so the first thing we did
is we started looking at all the
refunded orders right so these are
orders that you know either we gave a
refund for or that a bank has given a
charge back on and we were trying to
think about how can we get our
developers to know about these orders so
you can actually take that physical
vacuum cleaner back all right
so what we did is we actually let me
just walk you through an example so what
we did is we looked at all the other
refunded orders a user comes in to
Google Play maybe made a $10 purchase
for 10,000 coins right if we approve a
refund there what we do now is we store
those orders in a voided order table so
these orders are labeled as in do not
deliver or clawback with the API which
you can do as a developer you can call
this API it's called the voided
purchases API you can receive the data
on that order and you can then clawback
the item so what happens is the user
gets their B from the proof they get
their $10 right but once you call it API
and you have that order you can take the
10,000 gems back so we learned that this
works really really well for refunds and
have a next slide on impact so be
extending it to other types of orders as
well we looked at cancellations we
looked at banks or issuers giving
chargebacks out and we added those as
well and this works really really really
well for bad user it also works well for
good users because we believe that as a
good user you're okay getting back your
and willing to give up the coins that
you purchased with it so here's the
impact slide we've been partnering this
for about ten to twelve months but a
couple different developers we've seen
really really big impact everywhere so
on average we see refunds decrees with
more than sixty percent in about you
know two to three months time because
what happens is it takes time for the
community and it's basically for abusers
to find out that this abuse vector is
gone so now they get into a little bit
more details because of course you want
to know how can I do this for my game so
this is an early access API so you have
to sign up and we'll show you a link
later on and also send you the detailed
documentation so you don't have to take
pictures of this but broadly how imports
is um you give us the start time and the
end time of a time period for which you
want to have all the voided purchases
call our API we give you back a list of
orders keyed by purchase token and then
what you can do with that is you can use
that to revoke access to to those orders
let's talk me a little bit about like
the three different approaches that
we've seen developers use our data I'll
go from really really simple to more
complicated so the simplest way is user
purchases something like 10,000 coins
for ten dollars right we send you the
voided order and what happens is you
claw back exactly those 10,000 gems from
the users balance so the user is now the
current ban is minus 10,000 but of
course there's many many games where you
don't only get 10,000 gems but you get
10,000 gems plus like one or two or
maybe three special characters so that's
that's the second case that we've seen
is where developers say we don't only
clawback the 10,000 gems but also we
take anything that we added on to that
some special powers special characters
and the claw toes back as well the first
case that we see is I guess the most
complicated case is where you take
snapshots of the user state at the
moment of purchase so say this user
bought these 10,000 gems say two weeks
ago and with those 10,000 gems was able
to get two special characters and go up
three levels
what we've seen is developers who then
when they get to reform of order take
the user back two weeks right and then
the user is actually back three levels
loses their two to three special
characters and lose it at ten thousand
gems so this worked really well in
stopping abuse and we also really
believe that this works really really
well for good users so the gain axis of
course you need to have a developer
account registered with Google Play and
you need to have a game that accepts
in-app purchases so if you want to get
started this is the point where I would
take a picture because we don't have
this but there's a form that you can
fill out and then we'll whitelist you
for early access so John and I are like
really really excited to work with you
on this I think this is just the start
for us of getting a more balanced
economy where we really try to make the
online experience as fair and as
balanced as it is offline when you buy
your vacuum cleaner so kind of going
back to you know the goals we had in the
beginning right we started to create a
more balanced in a purchase economy by
allowing you to clawback these items
we're allowing access to all developers
it's early access now but I'm thinking
maybe next quarter will open up for
everybody everything goes well and this
creates wins for all of us so we really
see this as an open discussion between
you us and our users so if you have any
questions any suggestion from your
communities feel free to reach out to me
John or email addresses will be only on
the final slide so with that I actually
would like to invite to developers on
stage to share their perspective on Fair
Play which is going to be really really
exciting so while we bring up some
chairs I'd like to invite Emily Greer
who's the co-founder and CEO of
congregate and ridging Weiner who's the
head of community and player support for
a space ape and maybe we clap a little
bit while they put up the chairs
[Applause]
however way you want to do it works for
me um music musical chairs yeah well do
musical chairs yeah what's the fairest
way to do this is the question the
fairest way to do is is I get all the
chairs cool so maybe Emily maybe you can
start talk a little bit about your
background first and then Regina and
then we'll dive into some more questions
so i'm as i mentioned the co-founder and
CEO of congregate if you're not familiar
with congregate we started ten years ago
as a browser game platform kind of think
youtube for games uh not maybe not
appropriated it at a and android event
but an open platform where any developer
can upload a browser game we add a lot
of social features and in app
monetization in which case we were
responsible like google is now for the
fraud which on pc can be probably more
intense than on mobile so that's an
interesting experience and then we
continue to have that platform but about
three years ago we entered mobile as a
mobile publisher and have published more
than twenty-five games including some of
our recent hits include adventure
capitalists animation Throwdown which is
top fifty grossing on android and today
peter molyneux game called the trail
which is very interesting that lunch
today so you should check it out
congratulations on that
regina well give you a little background
so uh wow that's loud
my background is a little over 15 years
in gain the game industry starting out
at companies like Disney making a trip
through Nickelodeon and Cartoon Network
along the right way I'm finally ending
up at space ape games in London a little
over two years ago
my background is everything from
community support to a little bit of
development to localization management
to project management so my backgrounds
been varied and it's very much player
focused our company is founded on those
principles and when you have that you
have to be focused on every aspect of
development
great all is fair play great so Regine
let's let's stay with you can you maybe
talk a little bit about your philosophy
your company's philosophy around like
playing fair and level playing fields so
we are a company full of gamers we were
built on gamer and building our own
games and making sure that we enjoy them
and then making sure that our players
enjoying them so when something doesn't
feel right in the game it's not going to
reveal right to your players and because
we as players know that and play it
ourselves we're actually able to balance
the economy we're able to make sure that
if there is someone who as an edge case
is able to exploit the system we can
identify that because we're thinking
about doing it ourselves we always want
the advantage and players always want
the advantage and once you're so I feel
a few giggles in the crowd on that one
but it is one of those things when
you're looking at competitive gaming
making sure that you're looking at all
the different ways that your game can be
played and making sure that you
understand how it's going to be played
by the different users that you have in
your game we look at it from a level
playing field everyone from our spenders
who are non spenders because our
spenders wouldn't be in the game if our
non spenders weren't there to compete
with some of our non spenders are the
most creative individuals on the planet
who are able to compete against folks
who are spending thousands of dollars
that comes from a very well balanced
game given that information we actually
are very cognizant when you have an
advantage in the game and you didn't buy
it and you didn't earn it so we have to
make sure that when we can claw back
those different items as well and we get
a level playing field for both of those
audiences which aligns really well with
what we what we just presented I guess
Emily what about congregate hobbies so
one of our core strategic principles is
building long-term relationships and
that includes developers players
partners whoever and one of the core you
know poor precedents or something core
things that you face things that you
need to have to have a long term
relationship is you have to have trust
and build trust over the long term and
in a game and in almost any situation
it's impossible to build trust if you
don't have fairness there's other
elements like
pairen see and sort of emotional
connection but fairness is like the base
of the trust pyramid and has to be you
know with every decision that you think
about you have to you have to think of
fairness and you have to think of you
know your you have emotional responses
to fairness to what's fair to a
particular player but as part of
important part of community management
and player customer service is thinking
about what's fair broadly and not just
to an individual so let me ask you a
question about it so you start you see
fairness as a key part of trust um how
do you make sure that everybody in your
company is kind of lined on what's fair
because what's fair for me might be not
unfair for somebody else who's looking
at the same case right right um so um a
lot of this has been trial and error and
mistakes over the years and an
interesting because we're a platform we
get to see not only our own mistakes we
get to see the mistakes of developers
and so we get to see a sort of a wide
range of behavior and one of the things
coming out of various crises and things
that we've we've come as a core
principle is never do anything for
someone that you wouldn't do for
everybody or if you would do it for a
subset of people that you wouldn't be
okay
defending publicly on a forum on a live
chat and the that really helps clarify
what's fair is we say it publicly will
you defend it will all of us agree on it
and especially in a customer service
situation that's that's kind of the the
bedrock is can I stand can everybody
stand behind this and then once you hit
that mark then it's probably fair yeah
yeah I like that where you're saying the
key question for fairness is how I would
treat is one in the video is that how
are we trade everybody yeah and how is
everybody going to think about that and
how does it all play go together you
can't make everybody happy that's
completely impossible but there's a
different level of unhappiness if you
with I didn't
what I want but I see overall that this
is fair versus I got screwed and
everybody got screwed thanks for thanks
for sharing that perspective so we've
announced this API in this basement here
today and it is really exciting but I
wanted to actually talk to address this
question to Regine to talk to you about
your experiences integrating the API
because I believe you've had those and
tell us what it's like and you know if
you think it'll be valuable oh it's
heaven okay so it you guys laugh but
player experience starts with being able
to provide it to them if you don't know
that this is happening you don't have it
have a way of dealing with it it is very
difficult to look your players in the
face and say that's not happening in our
game so having access to the API and
being able to bring back and claw back
the items is very important the hardest
part of integrating this API is not the
API it is deciding the right way to
remove the items from your player so
that it's fair for everyone for example
if someone's going to come in use a
Gacha not get what they want refund
immediately and you're just going to
pull those stones or those Gacha items
away from them and for example in our
game it's a duplicate but duplicates
give you resources so it's valuable to
your play style anyway but if you're
going to actually just pull those
resources away from them you're not
going to have the same impact however if
you're going to clawback their last
crystal polls they can't game the system
against you you just pulled the top last
ten that they did half of the challenge
with implementing this is having three
different games with samurai siege rival
kingdoms and transformers earth wars and
deciding how we were going to approach
this in each of our games because it's
not about coins it's not about gems it's
not about a certain currency it's about
the gotcha items and the value of them
and taking that experience the other
thing you don't want to do is you don't
want to beat up a good player someone
came in they double tapped they weren't
paying attention when they made a
purchase okay everything happens to
somebody it's gonna happen you know if
if that happens twice every three months
it's acceptable that was never really
your money right and that's a different
issue yeah you know it happens so don't
beat your player up for that however if
someone goes to a restaurant 38
time's an aether meal 38 times they
leave the restaurant they call their
credit-card company and they get a
refund on that meal 38 times that is
criminal it is not something that you
should allow to continue to happen
beyond that you have other patrons in
that restaurant who are paying for those
same meal and are paying for the
opportunity to perhaps have that steak
that they couldn't have because someone
else paid for it refunded so you need to
make sure that you have a level playing
field and that you're providing them
with a response that is even unfair for
everybody you front you refund it was
more than twice this is how we handle it
guys I'm sorry that you've done that is
we remove the items from you so the
hardest part was deciding how you were
going to remove it from each game the
API itself is something that someone who
is base level technology skills can
actually do if your tech team is around
and has availability you can hand it off
to them and they'd have it done in an
hour
it's a batch process on a nightly basis
if you hook it into your system it's
great I would recommend actually running
it kind of ad-hoc it to begin with and
the reason why I say running an ad-hoc
is you want to be able to make sure that
you're removing the right things you
want to make sure there's no double
purchases in there you want to make sure
by the way the API now checks for that
so it's brilliant you want to make sure
that the players are actually hearing
this the other thing which is more
subtle is once you start doing this your
familiars your Cheers gang your MVPs
your VIP start talking to each other and
it helps keep the honest players honest
and it helped it makes the fraud guys
are going to do it forever but it helps
keeps the you know it's the lock on the
door there's a there's a group of
players who will you get have so much
fun exploiting things that they're
always going to exploit and there's
people who are so honest they'll always
be honest but that sort of the bell
curve are people who will live up or
down to their situation so once once
fraud gets going in a game it tends to
you know spiral out of control again and
then but the reverse is possible with
cleanup and we've seen that happen on
our platform with different games that
started out fine got into terrible abuse
problems and then
with hard work managed to get back to a
more even playing field we have
incredible white hats in our game that
when we started bringing all of the kind
of fraud back into check and removing
items from them they're like the writing
and going hey thank you for doing this I
didn't realize that somebody in my
alliance was doing this and we have zero
tolerance for that and being thanked for
that was a very odd experience it was
not the response I was expecting to see
and it's because you're leveling the
playing field and they no longer feel
like they're playing against themselves
yeah that's a that's a really good point
you know I think the beauty and the
simplicity of this API is that you get
to take you know what is a very simple
process which is a refund and apply it
in the right way to your game because
everybody here has a game that's
different from each other and it would
be hard to say like apply this one way
this one method to revoking a currency
and so you I think have done a really
great job of applying this in your game
in a way that makes sense for your
community Emily you're less sort of
familiar with the API I think and like
wanted to get your initial fee no I'm
only familiar with our attempts on web
to do something similar so but I'm
really excited that basically from the
moment that we came to mobile we were
looking to figure out if there was a way
we could do something like this and
there wasn't and now I can't tell you
how excited I am it's available we're
excited for you yeah I think maybe
taking it a little bit step back into
conversation we're talking about good
users versus bad users right so there's
always a small percentage of bad users
they will always keep on trying for
different types of motives right so how
do you deal with those like do you try
to identify them and then what are some
different mechanisms that you use Emily
maybe you want to want to go first yeah
you know nothing is ever have proof and
so oh and you could work on it forever
what how we organize our time is to
think about what's the level of impact
of the cheating
that comes down is going to be very
specific game to game to game and a lot
of it comes down to are you cheating
your own experience are you cheating
other people's experience the amount of
fraud and cheating that will tolerate in
a competitive multiplayer game is really
really really low but in a game like
adventure capitalist if there's a hack
where you can you know change your phone
and move time forward and there's no
leaderboards and there's no no impact to
anybody but your own sort of thrill at
progress we would like to stop that but
we're not going to put as much effort
into it it's not undermining the fun of
the game for other people so it's it's
more situational how much effort we'll
put into it um and the you know there's
situations that are sort of in between
like leaderboards for example in a
single-player game that is you know if
you you're playing a game and you see
nothing but hack scores and the
leaderboard it's not changing most of
your your feeling but then it cheapens
your your accomplishment so that's a a
lighter touch than a TV you know a pvp
competitive multiplayer game but it's
still affecting your impact so then well
especially on flash games on the web you
can't stop it but what we we've done is
sort of we identify what we think are
the cheater scores and we show cheater
leaderboards to cheaters and we show
non-shooter leaderboards to everybody
else and you know cheaters keep cheating
and get their fun out of that and then
people who aren't cheaters get it get a
true experience and that's how we manage
it in that situation but but in other
situations will be much more
zero-tolerance oh you're telling me that
my high score that I see all the time
actually not a real high score but I
fall into the cheater boards uh if
you've been cheating ya know when you
know it's never ever on that right it
was it was fake it's that then becomes a
competition is who of who's better at
cheating yes its own competition
legitimate of this level yeah but I
guess I guess in all seriousness what
you're saying is cheating is bad but as
various degrees of that and when it
impacts my good users to a certain
extent we talked about like Wars of
different clay
hands were like groups together that's
when it impacts the bad the right a bad
news about the good users and and its is
it impacting your your sense is it
impacting somebody else's progress
that's much worse than impacting
somebody's sense of achievement and yeah
Regine we were talking about this
earlier and you were you were talking
about some crafty ways that you guys
handled cheaters and some of the ways
that you sort of pooled them together I
don't know if you want to share some of
your experiences they're very similar to
what she does oh so it's something that
apparently we all haven't talked about
but I have a feeling we've been removing
cheaters from leaderboards for a very
long time but showing it to them so they
continue to think that they're on it and
not try and find other ways to exploit
issues but even beyond that it goes
right even down to kids games right you
have kids cursing in games and what you
do is you actually show them the curse
words to themselves so they get a kick
out of it but you don't show it to the
rest of your players because you're
impacting the majority of your player
base and in same thing goes with
cheating if someone is actually using
scores and they're continually running
up the leaderboard and they look a
little bit out of out of whack you move
them into a different leaderboard but
that's actually how we engaged with you
to begin with we monitor everything in
our in our economy and we found somebody
who is incredibly out of whack is the
only way to describe it we look at our
numbers every single week and we know
how many gems they have how many
diamonds they have how many items they
have how many items they should have and
given this it was leaps and bounds
higher than where it should have been
and you know it was one of those things
where 38 times and it was way more than
that he had gone to the restaurant and
was able to redeem the resources and it
was because of the number of times that
they have done it and how out of whack
the economy was that we were able to
actually identify the user
do you ever straight out ban users at
from from the game I think that the API
is about calling back the rewards but do
you do full bans there's a there's a
finite limit to our generosity it's it's
one of those things where if you're an
honest player and you've done it a few
times and we've given you and by the way
we do in-game warning
so it's not a surprise to anybody you
got to be fair to them you've got a set
of a message saying I also give the
morning that I'm doing it so it's not
that they've logged into their account
and all of a sudden it's calling it's
this is coming you've done it if you do
this again you're not welcome anymore
that kind of behavior has been able to
stop the majority these issues however
as with any game we have exploits and
when we detect the exploits because
something is out of bounds
we even better we we bounce them so they
compete they do they're it's it's one of
those things where we impede their
progress they're in there they're
playing their PvP they defeat the base
we detect the issue we boot them from
the game they come back they do it again
they get booted from the game they don't
get their resources they don't get their
gems they aren't able to gain any
advantage of it they aren't able to
continue their progress and for a while
it'll keep the honest people honest
however then we put it basically serves
as a honeypot because then people will
start changing the parameters to get it
just a little bit of an advantage and
those are the people that we look at
when we say okay this person is not a
good person they are not there to play
they're not there to enjoy it they're
there to exploit the systems and they
exploit other players and that's why we
ban I think that's actually a pretty
good segue to a next question it is so
we're going to launch this API everybody
is going to sign up what would you
advise other developers to like how to
charge you to start thinking about fair
play what is it like the one two three
of yeah yeah I mean the there's pretty
extreme examples depending on on the
type of game adventure capitalist is so
different from any other space case yeah
an RTS that the the level to which you
need to do things is very different I
mean I think the principle of what's the
impact to others as in how you deal with
it is it's a good guiding principle but
to get I don't think I can give you
anything more detailed than that because
it really is about your game and
different and different developers have
different tolerances and like ways they
want to run their game some developers
like it sits on principle or more
libertarian and
or more authoritarian and do you you
know that's your ultimately it's your
players experience but it's your game
and you can you can you can set those
ground rules and you would they would
probably implement the API differently
yeah I think but just to give like want
it but we've typically done in our in
our pilots is one to two weeks of data
analysis so just looking at histograms
of you know where are the outliers of
people or countries or levels where it
really looks like really really bad and
then I think the second thing you do is
like if you see lot of volume there how
does it impact others that's kind of
that's probably good way to think about
it and then how would you change your
game economy with the new information to
have to stop that egregious behavior I'd
also want to look at why I for example
if you're running a gotcha game and your
drop rates are far too low that it's
time to look at your gotcha rates if
your your gotcha rates are far too low
and your refunds are far too high it's
time to have a conversation I gets back
to actually to trust and to to fairness
is if players don't trust you they're
more likely to cheat it all they're also
more likely to cheat if they don't trust
each other but your honor you're you are
a factor in the equation one of the
things we've touched on in a few of
these conversations has been the role of
community and what that means for fair
play and they they sort of go hand in
hand in some ways because if you upset
your community people are going to leave
and potentially abandon your game but
could you tell me the how you think
about approaching community and the role
that it plays when you consider fair
play in your games you want to take a
first story and I mean I guess shortly
at what I would say is our goal is
community and fair play is a means to
creating a good community and that
community is sort of the is what lifts
say a game above a pedestrian experience
it makes it you continue to play a game
I mean you'll play a game only so long
just for being fun you'll play a game so
much longer if you have friends and if
you have an emotional connection to the
game and that's something that you get
from community and so you know fairness
is a means to that end
and and that's how I would how I think
about it so we love our players I know
you guys all say you love your players
with our players they are welcome to
come visit
that's how transparent we are
specifically the ways we communicate
with them are a little bit different
than a normal developer of course we put
our release and patch notes out of
course we put up a wiki of course we put
content and news feeds but beyond that
we they have access to as via band chats
they have access to via twitch our
developers are sitting in facebook pages
it's very strange but it's very
manageable I mean we have 20 to 30
million downloads the number keeps
growing obviously and when you think
about it at that scale you say how can I
attack this but you start with your
influencers and you bring them in and
you make sure that they understand and
they become your voice and you create a
relationship with them and then the
trust builds and when Trust is there
believe it or not it's going to affect
your bottom line because they're going
to play one game they're going to move
to your next game they're going to move
to your third game and you start
building brand affinity for your company
not just for your games and they trust
you so when something does go horribly
wrong as we all know as developers they
do hourly particularly at launch time so
I I feel for you today it's gonna be a
long night
when you launch having that trust in
that affinity and the transparency to be
able to say hey listen guys I
acknowledge it in truth with your on
being very truthful with your players
gives them a little more breathing room
to say hey you know what you guys messed
up I'm gonna let it go I'm going to give
you a bye on this one but make sure you
take care of them would you want to have
for example would you have a not want to
have an item taken away from you would
you want to have would you want to have
one player receiving one bundle and
another player receiving a different
type of bundle for half the cost you
wouldn't want that so when those issues
pop up make sure that you treat players
fairly and they'll trust you more and
they'll spend more because they trust
you the other thing I will say is we
managed
4x7 support we do in 11 different
languages about 30 or so folks we're
embedded inside of the game teams each
game team has a ccs lead they feed back
to the agents our ages can talk to our
developers at any points so they don't
feel like they're having a conversation
with an anonymous Stella developer and
they do you see the actions are
resulting in you know feedback is being
taken and implanted so so Google is a
very data-driven company or known for
being a david data driven company and
one of the things were always into is
measuring and so do you in this
community and this trust aspect how do
you measure community trust or do you
measure it because I'm sure some
developers are in the audience thinking
like you know like I could spend an
extra effort like go through like
providing twitch streams and providing
kind of 24/7 support but how do you
measure the community trust or sentiment
if you do player purchases retention
lifetime value and you can throw it
right in relations - absolutely if you
looked at a lifetime value of a company
that doesn't have support versus a
company that does have support you would
find it significantly higher for
community events live events in game it
shows that it's active and alive and
they're willing to stay for that oh yeah
I would say it's it's hard to measure
directly retention is going to be the
the best measure by far long-term
retention obviously not not short-term
and one of the things that we like to
look at is momentum on and look at RIT
not pure retention but looking at ratios
of retention so how you know what's your
your change from D 7 to D 30 what's your
change from D 30 to D 90 because
different games and different genres are
going to have different baselines but
that tells you a lot about that
experience so that's one way of looking
at it but that's still a lot of that is
going to come down to the game you know
I one thing is you know what when you
see it if you go into a forum you can
tell really quickly what the overall
sentiment
and in ten minutes and now you can't
measure that and track it in a really
clear way but we do we do do some
tracking our community management do
weekly summaries and sometimes daily
summaries for developers and talk about
sentiment and we track that over time
but and then the other thing that we do
is just tracking fraud rates on
purchases over time and that you know
that's not going to tell you strengthen
community but it tells you when things
are going off the rails and that you you
will see that happen pretty quickly and
when you will see it come back down as
well that can be extremely dramatic so
we do win back rates because players in
the RTS Tirana will burn out pretty
quickly nine months and they'll say I
need a break
question is do they come back a month
and a half later because they're
invested in your community they're
resting in the game they're invested
they've taken their break that's a very
interesting metric to look at do they
come back to you to reconnect with them
and say hey your accounts always going
to be here and we put some extra goodies
in there you know if they come back you
know you're doing right if they don't
come back and you have a very high
percentage of opens and they just delete
it that also is a very interesting
metric because I saw it they opened it
they looked at it and they said yeah
yeah it's similar to like long term
retention with them winter break I was
wondering if there's any questions from
the audience be we still got some time
so okay so yeah we can shout them out or
use the microphone or both you ever done
any cohort analysis on your high value
consumers who have actually gone through
this fraud we our return system yeah so
here's the great news there are multiple
different ways of implementing this you
can put these people into the negative
and make them rear and back up and you
see them do that if they're actively
engaged and if you see for example your
golden Co heart just refunds his entire
account that guy's never coming back
regardless and it's it's really
interesting do it because the other
thing it does is increase increases of
the trust with the existing players so
they don't feel like they're spending
into a black hole
your MVPs
are talking to each other every single
day whether they're talking through the
systems that you've provided or they're
online or they're using banned or
they're on Facebook or they're using any
other mechanism but they are talking to
each other and as soon as one person
says you know listen I refunded and this
happened to me it sweeps through your
entire community and that you know what
the majority of people like I'm glad
they're finally doing that that was so
unfair that this guy had been doing that
for six months and they start spending
more it's been a nice bump yeah and what
I would say is if you if you do
something that the player doesn't like
but seems fair they will retain and
we've seen that because we have so many
games on our web platform we've had
games a particular Chinese game that had
a very different idea of community
management and customer service that our
players were expecting went into a
full-blown crisis that resulted in I
think 70% of players requesting refunds
from us in one month and we we worked
through I mean that was trial by fire
and a lot of of like 10:00 p.m. phone
calls with translators to try and work
through it and what ended up happening
is we managed to save about half of the
players to the game and the rest of the
players we managed to save to the
platform and that they still didn't
trust the game but they trusted us in
terms of our attitude and that was five
years ago and pretty much every one of
the big spenders who went through we
went who we went through that with it's
still an active spender on the Congress
formed so they weren't they weren't
happy but they were and there was and we
did call back a lot of stuff and and
some from the game but kept them on a
platform complicated things but you can
keep them and they're really really
worth keeping the people who are most
upset are the people most worth keeping
passion yeah
I actually have two questions okay so my
first question is how transparent are
you guys with the community in terms of
like when you guys are implementing
bands or like showing evidence or is it
just like very like mysterious like hey
we've caught these caught these things
like how much communication do you have
down to the specifics if I'm talking to
you and into your account you know what
you've done you don't know how I know
but you know what you've done if I am
talking to someone who's trying to talk
to me about you my relationship is with
you my relationship is not with your
Alliance leader so we do tell them that
this is what we're doing we do tell them
that this is how we're handling refunds
it's on our FA cues it's in in the
public domain that this is how we handle
things and that we do a deal with it and
address it however I will never discuss
a player's account with someone that's
not the player and then the thank-you
and then the second question I have is
whether with the clawback API or just
clawbacks and bands in general are there
common pitfalls in which you guys have
been over aggressive or you know things
to avoid there is so make sure you under
it make sure you're logging everything I
mean that's the reality of the game you
have to make sure you log it so that you
know what you're taking away the other
thing is take a snapshot before you take
anything away just in case you get it
wrong and then if you do get it wrong
vehicle button give them something a
little extra for your error
don't be shy about it and don't try and
hide it the other thing I'll tell you is
that when you are cloning back something
the player has done something they
should not have done and if they are a
good player they acknowledge it and say
listen you know what I got a refund I'm
not entitled to this if they're a bad
player and they're like but I have spent
forty five hundred dollars with your
company and I only refunded five hundred
and seventy of it like yeah that's five
hundred and seventy errors you don't get
to keep it and I do want to understand
why that person does it so it's helpful
and we're able to gather feedback from
it but in the end you've done something
you knew shouldn't have been doing
you've been caught let's deal with it
that way maybe do your first grade
so in our pilots we've seen different
types of communication so we had seen
one developer went out created a website
at the community managers talked to the
community and every time when you refund
the order gets clawed back you actually
have an in-game message that's blocking
that's like a pop-up and it shows up in
your inbox as well we have all the
developers who do it more in the backend
where they still take the gems away and
send you an email so we kind of simple
it really depends on how close you are
but your community going you know you
always do it in-game I can't read it
enough the other thing is um whatever
your communication with with a player
expect that it will be copy pasted and
cue other players to into forums etc so
again like being really really
consistent on your policies and a lot of
time that means like just getting
everybody together and like
whiteboarding out exactly what you're
going to do arguing it out and getting
it straight so that you can have that
total consistency and if it's a you know
it's a major error especially you know
if you've made a mistake and you're
trying to make it right you want that
totally public and and in in in your
face something that's more individual
yes keep it individual but again if you
if you would mind having this email in
your forums don't write that email it's
really interesting we actually so sorry
are we over time you can finish your
thought and then we're gonna finish up
all right so you as everyone knows we
had an outage an issue with an attack on
the East Coast and it's right during an
event and when you're doing live events
you are feeling it for the players
because they want to get in there and
they want to play and it's a hard
Alliance event well what do you do for
players like listen I just lost 12 hours
of this 36 hour event or this 48 hour
event in it it results in refunds
because they're like listen I spent this
money I couldn't use it I got in
sporadically what you do in that
instance is you extend the events if you
can do it but if you can't you need to
level the playing field for everybody
who took part to get it and you need to
be vocal about it you can't just say oh
well you're lost that's not the right
way to develop a relationship
your your audience your plight seems
like a really good note to end on rejeen
Emily thank you so much for joining
[Applause]